now that you've seen the weather entry
class for the weather table it's your
turn
add the constants for the location table
in the location entry inner contract
class these constants include the table
name and the name of each column as
we've shown in a few previous diagrams
the columns need to store the location
setting latitude longitude and the city
name after you finish coding the
location entry class make sure to look
at the solution video you'll want to use
the same constant names that we use
since the code and the other classes you
receive relies on these constant names
being the same once you've finished
we'll have to find all of the columns
for both of the tables next we'll be
ready to use these column names to
actually create the tables in the
database